c'est une terre rude et puissante
balayée par les cyrs un vent glacé qui
pénètre les os isoler 5 mois de l'année
le plateau de l'Aubrac n'est pas a
priori un lieu où l'on s'arrête pourtant
un village en a fait sa force sa
réputation même et son nom rayonne bien
au-delà du Massif Central layol c'est un
couteau mondialement connu une centaine
d'ouvriers travaillent à la forge vide
l'hiver les couloirs se remplissent
l'été le village qui compte 1200
habitants à l'année voient passer à la
belle saison plus de 70 000 touristes en
deux mois pendant quatre saisons nous
avons accompagné ceux et celles qui font
vivre ce village car Laguiole ce n'est
pas juste un couteau
[Musique]
plus que l'autre
l'autre
avec d'autres éleveurs il se bat pour
préserver la race Aubrac l'autre trésor
de ce plateau
un plateau que sillonne Hervé stork le
vétérinaire
arrive c'est magnifique
[Musique]
à 50 ans ce savoyard a quitté si haute
montagne pour tenter l'aventure à la
hotte
il y a du boulot il espère que sa femme
et ses cinq enfants le rejoindront dans
quelques mois
la yole a beau être enclavé ce village
rural a encore son école
une trentaine d'enfants y est scolarisé
vous gagnez le concours
la décoration à l'intérieur et Alexandre
on est le 23e directeur
c'est très bien les enfants
l'un des enfants de la yole a choisi à
l'âge adulte de rester il travaille
perché sur les hauteurs
[Applaudissements]
Sébastien brachève trois étoiles il est
né et a grandi ici
sa cuisine c'est celle de l'Aubrac et
les clients viennent du monde entier
pour la découvrir on est vraiment au
service de dame nature parce que on peut
travailler à contre-courant de ce que
nous offre le plateau
son restaurant nous allons le voir
évoluer pendant quatre saisons
comme tout le reste du village
de la solitude de l'hiver au première
balade du printemps
des vacances en famille au milieu des
touristes au retour des troupeaux à
l'automne
avant que le froid ne vienne à nouveau
isoler le village